the weekend has barely started and we
have what may be a campaign ender from
Donald Trump it turns out that he was
caught on a hot mic back in 2005 talking
to Billy Bush saying you can do anything
you grab him by the [ __ ] talking about
women talking about bragging about he
kisses women when he wants he gropes
women when he wants and Donald Trump has
immediately put out a statement saying
hey this was locker room banter it was a
private conversation it took place many
years ago and Bill Clinton has said far
worse to me on the golf course there's
nothing that you can criticize Donald
Trump for that he can't link in some way
to Hillary Clinton or Bill Clinton you
criticized Trump's foundation they're
barred from fundraising they are by the
New York Attorney General they have been
caught using charitable donations for
political use which is a huge huge
violation of tax law if you call Trump
out on it hey look at the Clinton
Foundation of course the entire critique
of the Clinton Foundation based on a
tweet from The Associated Press that
since been retracted you look at Trump's
critique of Hillary Clinton that she was
for the Iraq war and he's always would
have been against it well there's video
of him talking a audio of him talking to
Howard Stern and video of him and one
other interview I can't recall where
he's clearly open to and in favor of
arguably the invasion of Iraq there is
nothing that he can't blame Bill or
Hillary Clinton for caught red-handed
here basically
glamourizing the sexual harassment and
sexual assault of women saying he
decides what he does to women it doesn't
matter what they do and sometimes you
got to grab him by the [ __ ] this this
has to end it right I mean it's that
this has to be the end for Trump I know
that he's already made about a hundred
comments that should have uniquely
disqualified him from being president of
the United States and laughed him out of
the race but he continues in in part
because of just the sheer sheer lack of
information that so many of his voters
have as we know is this going to be it
for Donald Trump we're heading into a
long weekend the question I would love
for you to answer in the comment
is is this it for Trump or is there
going to be some way that he continues
could this be the equivalent of Mitt
Romney's 47% moment and you know when we
think about percentages here
Mitt Romney insulted 47% of Americans by
saying 47% of Americans will always be
takers and not makers Donald Trump has
offended somewhere between 50 and 51
percent of America directly insofar as
that's the percentage of women that we
have in this country as a percent
percentage of the population but really
how can anyone who either is a woman
knows a woman respects a woman or has a
mother how could anyone fitting into any
of those categories justify voting for
Donald Trump after such a vile and
heinous comments of leak then I know I'm
gonna get emails from the anti justice
social justice warriors I'm gonna get
emails from the the men's rights
activists I'm gonna get emails from
those claiming that they're just against
political correctness when it's
overbearing believe me I've taken plenty
of heat for speaking out against
overbearing and if and and sort of
destructive political correctness that
is not what this is about is this it for
Donald Trump